Well,
I mean,
you hear about some of the experiments they did on people.
Man,
that was scary.
This doctor supposedly I think came in with the operation paperclip.
Oh,
she signs.
It goes that deep into,
oh my God,
that's horrible.
It's pretty fucked up.
It's,
it's,
you know,
operation.
Do you know what operation paperclip was?
Isn't that something like a Hitler thing back in the day with babies?
No,
no,
no.
It was the Nazi scientists that were taken from World War II.
So the United States took Nazi scientists,
including Wernher von Braun,
who was the head of NASA,
a bunch of other scientists and all these Nazis that were working for Germany
making rockets and involved in like high level science.
They brought them over to America and sort of whitewash the whole thing.
They called it operation paperclip,
holy Wernher von Braun.
When he was at the head of NASA,
he was a fucking legitimate Nazi,
like the Simon Wiesenthal Center,
so that if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes against humanity.
I feel like there's still,
you know,
there's still
people in there.
Well sort of.
They've chased those guys down to the far ends of the earth.
[inaudible] a bunch of them.
Those are very powerful positions to be in,
to have that sort of mentality driving it.
That's scary as fuck for sure.
You know what's really crazy is Argentina,
Argentina,
and South America.
A lot of Nazis went to Argentina and South America.
They fled Germany and Tim Kennedy,
who's a good friend of mine,
who was a former UFC fighters,
a soldier,
he was on a show called finding Hitler where there was,
there's been speculation over the years because so many Nazis landed in South
America that Hitler had escaped and lived out his life in,
in,
you know,
protected by these other Nazis.
And these South American towns,
like there's towns in South America too.
There's towns in South America where they,
all they do is speak German.
They have October fast.
They have photographs on their walls of their grandfather and ss garb.
That is very,
very scary.
Oh dude,
it's crazy.
Very scary.
He blew me away when I,
when I'm,
when he was telling me about this and just great.
And he's a no nonsense guy.
So when he's explaining,
he's like,
you got to understand you're coming to these towns.
Everyone is German.
Oh my God.
They all look like Germans.
They all talk German.
They all have German like houses and German,
like the,
the like German style stuff in their house.
This bizarre fucking crazy to be what happened.
I,
no,
it's maybe not what happened to Hitler.
They're pretty sure they Hitler died,
but I'm sure they relocated and that's definitely what happened.
See if you could find that.
Yeah,
Jamie,
we'll find somebody stole it.
It'll blow you away.
This is just a South America look.
It looks like a German town.
German dude.
It's crazy.
There's a whole village,
these fucking people,
and there's not just one.
There's many,
many of these little little pockets that looks like an Oktoberfest bar.
That's really bizarre.
I mean,
that one looks a little Japanese that well,
there's videos though.
It's really crazy.
They're drinking out of steins and like the whole deal.
That's a really wild dude.
It's crazy.
Well,
obviously we couldn't get them all.
I mean,
they had to flee somewhere and they're going to set up shop,
make it there.
You know,
make it,
they're homogenous.
They saw the shit was about to hit the fan.
I said,
listen,
I know place.
We can get some cool Margarita's we can catch some fucking toast away.
Y'All want a day?
Let's bring Oktoberfest South America.
That's all wild.
I never knew that.
Oh,
it's,
yeah.
I didn't know it either.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
I see.
May I think there's too much to know.